all right moving on now we've got newly
released court documents in a lawsuit
from the election technology company
Dominion you've heard the name before
Dominion claims that Fox News believed
one thing about the 2020 election and
yet said the opposite on its air Fox
chairman Rupert Murdoch testified under
oath that he does not believe the
election was stolen from Donald Trump
and he also said that some Fox News
hosts went too far and all this talk of
knowing one thing and saying another
comes as Fox News hosts Tucker Carlson
continues to press a series of phony
claims about the January 6 assault on
the capitol Scott McFarland is on
Capitol Hill for us once again Scott
good morning Tony good morning two years
and two months after the deadly attack
here at the U.S Capitol Fox News is
defending itself against this 1.6
billion dollar defamation lawsuit but at
the same time one of its most popular
hosts is going on the offense trying to
rewrite the history of January 6th in
front of millions of viewers
the latest emails and text messages
revealed in Dominion voting systems
lawsuit against Fox News show fox head
Rupert Murdoch expressed concern about
what his hosts were saying after the
2020 election there are a lot of serious
issues surrounding the state's Dominion
voting machines in an email to CEO
Suzanne Scott Murdoch wrote maybe Sean
Hannity and Laura Ingram went too far
and when Dominion lawyers asked during
his January deposition have you ever
believed Dominion was engaged in a
massive and coordinated effort to steal
the 2020 presidential election Murdoch
replied No in fact on January 5th 2021
Murdoch suggested his Prime Time Stars
should acknowledge Joe Biden won the
election according to court documents
days before January 6th host Tucker
Carlson sent a text message to another
Fox employee saying he can't wait until
he can stop covering Trump adding quote
I hate him passionately for 26 months
that footage was held from the American
public the document surfaced Tuesday
just as Carlson began a second night of
coverage spinning a false Narrative of
the deadly Capital riots his program
aired select Capital police video
released to him exclusively by house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy it was neither an
Insurrection nor deadly Monday night he
fictitiously called the angry mob that
injured more than 140 officers mostly
peaceful there was resounding backlash
on Capitol Hill Tucker Carlson is a
propagandist publicly pretending to be a
newsman some senior Republicans also
denounced Carlson's claims I think it's
it was not just some Rowdy
peaceful protest of Boy Scouts Capitol
Police Chief Tom manger sent a memo to
the department Tuesday morning saying
the opinion program was offensive and
misleading saying allegations officers
acted like tour guides were false and
that those officers did their best use
de-escalation tactics I want to
associate myself entirely
with the opinion of the chief of the
Capitol Police
about what happened
on January 6th CBS News caught up with
speaker Kevin McCarthy who said he has
no regrets about sharing video with
Carlson but is yet to release it to
other news organizations look I I didn't
see what was aired when I've trans
wanted to
do and transparency to everybody and
everybody can make up their own
as for that Dominion lawsuit in a
statement late last night Fox News
called the latest court filings
distortions and said it's a PR campaign
aimed at smearing Fox Tony
all right Scott thank you very much